botar o meu nome americanos no méxico
onde serão essencialmente energia solar
em 18 acho é que a faculdade de ciências
e tecnologias da universidade nova de
lisboa
enquanto isso que temos de ter é que
existia era conhecimento frisch de
linhas de eventos intelectuais e percebi
que não queria perder a oportunidade de
jogar comigo viagem fantástica no viagem
de autoconhecimento conhecimento assim
hoje em falar sobre o erro não parece
muito promissor tradicional e
conceituada em gastos então isso dizer
que errar é humano é com os erros que se
aprende o hotel podendo conseguem não
durou muito
cai então destino vargas 1 que tem mais
fundo para um extrato talvez não seja
assim tão simples e bonito
vou tentar conquistar 16 acima são da
tua ajuda durante setecentos e quarenta
e cinco segundos também ex avaí nos
diariamente somos bombardeados com novos
conceitos em grande de máximas muito
treino e ver como o sir empreendedor
criar o vovô interno ao criar políticas
diversificadas se do negócio que a
intervenção numa política autor criativa
não faz ideia quer dizer existe existe
será isto é a valorização de iniciativa
e da autonomia
talvez seja mas o fato é que muitas
vezes mas não parece que o ponto ter um
rabo de uma geração da nossa geração que
é obrigada é inventar a possibilidade de
estudar a possibilidade de emprego
conseguir a estabilidade neste processo
que se desenrola em catadupa de porque
vi nada assim
em que nos dizem que não podemos cometer
temos que ser competitivos não espero
nada eu acho que perde perde seu tempo e
perde os passes precisos criativo esse
cliente virar importante dizer ao poder
e tinha mesmo ingênuo é muito nova que
atingir até aqui não é chamada
nós precisamos é de um bruxo produzir
aqui é muito bom tem o exclusivo ao ar
amanhã
não consegui tirar é humana o que pode
ser mais criativo e criar conhecimento a
partir do erro
acho que é uma coisa de todos estamos de
acordo o erro é um fugiu porém dão é o
fuji e fugiu incompatível com
pragmatismo o nosso cotidiano e se
destina a tentativa de nos tornarmos uma
geração altamente otimizada surgiu em
essas ferramentas que nos ajudou a
pintar a famíla temos pensar por exemplo
nos guia jurídicos olhos e econômico só
temos guias de jardinagem que nos
ensinam como fazer gol aí conto antara
cimento como não errar mas os repasses
tento é teimoso e um erro pode mudar até
nossa percepção daquilo que nos cuidar
eu mostro como foram muito simples vamos
pensar no sentido nossa visão
vocês sabem que o que nós questionamos
através da visão é apenas parte do que
pode ser pressionado
esta é a imagem que hoje não é um
símbolo exato da rotina em nosso cérebro
existe uma região chamada tala essa
região é é responsável por receber a
informação é importante porque cantar
outra toda a informação que precisa de
um procedimento rápido e depois por
outra tinham chamada córtex e informação
é percebida é compreendida a uma região
do cérebro que é responsável por
esconder ou o que seja que o objeto se
trata ea outra região que é responsável
por responder ou onde as agendadas as
características do objeto diz como é que
eu e orientação espacial um textura por
aí fora
além disso é que o que nós presenciamos
através da visão
também influenciam as nossas
experiências passadas tanto com vê aqui
uma grande panóplia de fatores que
influenciou que influenciam uma
experiência tem feito muito subjetivo
mas é importante perceber que nossa
mente está equipada de cães nos media
center e santos que nos ajudou a fintar
a inflação errada e talvez aquela que é
feito às vezes vocês vêem na imagem a
voz esquerda linhas mais facilmente o
que inclui os que nos cercam organiza e
sim e é por isso que vocês vêem a imagem
que está você vir até figuras
geométricas quando elas efetivamente
estão lá nós conseguimos computar as
meninas muito bem o que acontece quando
eu mostro isto como diria é calma eu já
tinha
eu sei que eu ganhar não é melhor que e
isso é que as outras linhas 1 tortas tem
razão tem toda a razão se o zot k2 é
coisa de ahvaz quando nós começamos a
misturar sentir isso e agora convidados
a fazer uma experiência única
quero fazer uma coisa muito simples quer
conter um dos passos que o perigo existe
dos brancos vão fazer ou seja não diz
que trocou a bola entre elas vão
experimentar
i
o bairro contaram sim enquanto e
contaram digam quem tem seis respostas
certas um só espaço
agora digam quantas pessoas que viram o
gorila pessoal atrás do banco do brasil
a importante tanto algumas pessoas
estavam focadas encontrar encontrar um
outro passo e agora digam-me quantas
pessoas viram que o fundo vermelho
coragem qual tem um dos dois criminosos
sim que isso acontece e acontece porque
nossa atenção e altamente coletiva
quando usou uma tarefa consiste em
trouxe aquela tarefa que os dois fizeram
o texto corretamente como alguns fizeram
foi encontrado num espaço de seu espaço
mas talvez alguns cacos e um vídeo e
achava que tava itajaí vai aparecer um
gorila estavam atentos a gorila não é
velado hoje ele fez isso mas é que o que
é preciso um novo fim mudança da cor do
fomos expulsos que estavam centradas
encontraram espaço virou fúria não viram
isso sentem vulneráveis agora greve não
é então vou ainda mais fundo o piorar a
situação porque quer faça é uma outra
experiência a essas crenças têm a mania
que é assim desde então uma nova
experiência que percebam o que a senhora
está a dizer ah ah ah ah então
conseguido ba com um beijo
vou passar exatamente o mesmo modo mas
convive um ligeiramente diferente
a crise agora tem percebido o nome de
facto é que isto acontece uma coisa é
chamado de efeito nuca acontece porque
nós oposição entrou em conflito com
nossa visão e nossa visão nossa equipe
mundial tanto nós é ter que ouvir esse
não é o primeiro que avisam que se
avizinham troca dos votos e faz com que
o estado de coisas que efetivamente um
2011 de agora vou passar exatamente o
mesmo áudio missa a imagem para o
interessado também pode ver aqui é que o
erro e usando sentido tem sido estudada
nos mais diferentes vertentes mais
diversas vertentes ao longo da história
o efeito visto como exemplo estamos com
a irmã energia com os podem instruir em
piúma aguente uma mistura com 51 diz não
sentir de forma absolutamente incríveis
e nós gostamos de ser enganados não
estamos
uma outra coisa óbvia como outros 80
óbvio em que foi curada em arte para
dispensar facilmente nas obras de achas
que eu uso muito o erro na perspectiva
eu aos teus falava comida definindo que
pintou chamado de loureiro e um desenho
de agosto muito cansado e pergunto é
porque eu disse que tinha pintado linha
fiquei muito cansada pintasse uma linha
de fundo sem que seja difícil perceber o
fato é comum e ciência a experiência que
correndo bem informal na arte de mel
linhas certas linhas erradas
isso fez lembrar uma história sobre o
crescimento está a si mesmo aqueles que
eram pintor euros essencialmente
figurativo luxo no século 19
alguns em 1910 juntava seu estúdio
testada pintar o ar livre durante a
manhã toda pedroso obra foi a sua vida e
quando voltou francisco obra
completamente diferentes porque o
corpitcho dependurado quadris pernas pro
ar
nela uma figura sem qualquer significado
prático mas ainda assim em suas palavras
pintadas de uma luminosidade anterior
como a autora ensina instagram no
facebook a primeira coisa que tem
desfecho foi cruel mas eu fico quatro
crias que quase frt/tras emílio não foi
nada disso
quem disse foi pintar uma agora ela
ficou conhecido na história como a
primeira obra um treinamento express e
mista de arte e ciência uma coisa óbvia
são tantas as invenções podem ser
associadas é casos por isso o hexa do
flamengo
alguns em 1921 e trabalhava em um ônibus
uma bactéria chamada ctf lopes ao
exercê-lo quitéria é responsável pelo
seu sucesso
a forma das filhas abertas os
privilégios pelas vítimas da guerra
hoje ter certa influência entrar deixado
na caixa pt o que se tenta nós fizemos
as culturas de bactérias é em cima de
uma bancada quando voltou viu que a
cultura que estava chegando hoje pensam
em deitar fora mas quando se for assim
em vir com mais atenção
rio num local onde parecia o google não
tinha mais o que teria atingido o que
seria
fui me conheceu assim existência de um
fundo chamado nenhum produz uma
substância chamada por um silvina que
matas afirmou que os olhos mas há mais
exemplos pois marca foi inventado em
1956 como engenheiro na porta me engana
que eu queria fazer um aparelho fosse
capaz de gravar o batimento cardíaco
eu vou fazer uma coisa totalmente
inversa em que é pulsos elétricos
clientes usavam nosso entendimento com
ele alguns durante a segunda guerra
mundial
o governo norte americano que se
inventasse um produto novo uma
substância que o substituiu silicone nos
votos dos combatentes
james whitey bulger o trabalho certo
prêmios que as suas mangas que o assunto
se os regentes e conseguiu produzir uma
máfia uma massa amorfa sem qualquer
funcionalidade prática só que a juntar
com alguma coisa alguma criatividade
neste ou duas piscinas eo viagra bem o
famoso comprimido azul era pra ter sido
de agra é fazer o que queria era criar
um medicamento que tentassem hipertensão
ea cultura enfrentar outras coisas então
mas eles entraram inclusivamente sítio
que inventou mais de mil maneiras como
não fazer uma antes de ter inventado
portanto temos aqui tantas evidências
que tornou o erro
alguns dos inquilinos muito custo disso
continuamos a vê los como algo mau
eu acho que a principal razão é
essencial é cultural e que sabem
condição de que nem sobre eventuais
avião assim é denegrir um erro que nós
criamos criamos uma estrelinha na folha
do bom comportamento e queremos ter boas
notas que é para ser compensados depois
com o tempo de o que acabou de ser e
quando achamos que temos que observar
seus vídeos emocionalmente
profissionalmente
queremos comprar o flamengo em carro
novo ter uma casa com vista para o mar e
férias país em verdade queremos que nos
dêem uma palmadinha nas costas de nosso
engenheiro fez um bom trabalho
o conhecimento dos outros é muito
importante para nós não é difícil
questionar uma coisa será que o que nos
desagrada no erro é um erro em si é o
foco está no cerrado
a pressão que temos de que estamos
errados é que sabe o passe para o golo
com a camisola do v escola o problema
ela protege do frio nem mesmo o sindicel
marié tens a etiqueta de fora pensa ah
tem etiqueta de fora é chato e
desagradável porque não está nos
conformes em reduzi para dentro
o conformismo aqui é um exemplo perfeito
em si mesmo é que é fácil assim de cama
nada é fácil cometer os erros em grupo
porque estamos suportá-los uma
comunidade que é ver conosco
pergunto o e consagrados por ser
limitado e inútil ou antes apenas porque
é diferente porque em previsível
proponho que passemos a ver o erro como
aquilo que o é como algo positivo como
algo que vai ter que o que é certo eo
resultado uma razão próprio não se
iludam podem ser a razão do caminho
normal mas é uma razão própria e cinco
anos devidamente nós eu juro que eu
passo de janelas de fundamento incríveis
que nos podem levar à descoberta da
lâmpada
a invenção do ostracismo um estudo
interessante efetuado uma universidade
norte americana de michigan percebeu que
as pessoas que têm uma postura positiva
relativamente ao erro ter uma atividade
cerebral de frente isto concluo com
várias em vídeo na mesma sala e
basicamente mostrava eu conhecia começam
conseguem ver muita coisa que eu tinha
de fazer e indicaram letra do mais não
parece complicado mas ao fim de algumas
horas os fiéis começavam a ficar
cansados e começavam em casa pois o que
os viram é que aquelas pessoas que não
se mostravam frustrados uma eventual
erro
tinha uma tiragem sobrado em frente e
rafão - vez e tenha um tempo
o preço muito inferior tanto como vem é
positivo seus positivos relativamente ao
erro
se for liquidada humana é uma condição
em orientação mais aprendemos a viver
com ela forma construtiva é que sabem
quando nós pensamos que temos todas as
respostas e vida acontece trocamos as
voltas e muda todas as perguntas
a partir desta tese festa top estou
fazer qualquer disparado conversa que
dizer hoje estava perfeitamente
enquadrados os erros são todos positivos
aqui estou no meu território
correndo o risco de acabar com o direito
ao push e acredito profundamente que
podemos aprender com os nossos erros
soubermos explorar devidamente as suas
possibilidades
resta me agradecer a vossa atenção
médida que o senhor que podemos ser uma
linha filho da mãe e dos jogos e todos
uma vida cheia de bezerros